so let's just add a little more detail
to the people who are not familiar with
the story with the region
with the evictions for the courts so
first of all Shake Your Eyes in East
Jerusalem maybe you can say what is
Jerusalem where is it located
what are we talking about in terms of
regionally
and second what kind of people that live
there so if you could talk about the
Palestinian people
and
um we should also make clear that these
evictions is literally people living in
homes and their homes are taken away
from them
I suppose technically it's legal
uh evictions but you're saying that
there's a asymmetry of power in the
courts where the legal is uh not so much
legal but it's uh politically and maybe
even religiously based
yeah I mean the biggest the most
important context here is that
oftentimes Americans think that Israel
and Palestine are some kind of two
neighbor two neighboring countries
um
that live next to each other and they
are at War but the fact of the matter is
Palestinian cities exist
um all over the country and it's just
one country it's just one infrastructure
and Israel is literally on top of
Palestine it was established on top of
our Villages
um in the late 40s uh now according to
international law the eastern part of
Jerusalem is under occupation so Israeli
presence
Dixon
over the area it's completely
illegitimate they say the evictions are
legal because the settlers
write their laws obviously they're going
to allow settlements to expand but
according to international law according
to even U.S policy
um
Israel occupies the eastern part of
Jerusalem it's jurisdiction there is
illegitimate we shouldn't even be going
to their courts in the first place but
we have no other option
we're talking about generations and
generations and generations of people
who have lived there
for the longest time who now even though
you know for example me I don't have a
citizenship I'm a resident a mere
resident I have a blue ID card even
though my grandmother and my grandfather
were born in Jerusalem their
grandparents were born in Jerusalem
um even though we've lived there for
Generations but Palestinians in
Jerusalem we are not Citizens We're just
mere residents same thing with residents
of the occupied Syrian Golan they are
not citizens they are just residents in
their own hometowns
um this is an important uh piece but all
of this gets convoluted and Lost in
Translation and I think
I I would argue it's a lot more it's
a lot of the time it's dubious it's it's
malicious the fact that these little
pieces of context that frame the entire
story get lost
you know I'll talk to you about
something else
um just 10 minutes 10 minutes across
from my neighborhood
another neighborhood called silhouette
and the people in Silvan are also
threatened with expulsion but not
through evictions but through home
demolitions and if you look at American
state American Media or Israeli State
media you would read the headlines you
know Palestinians living in homes built
illegally are gonna face you know their
homes as they're going to be torn apart
what these headlines don't tell you and
even sometimes most of the time the
substance doesn't tell you that
Palestinians seldom ever get
building permit applications
um in fact recently a spokesperson for
the Israeli military confirmed that was
95 of building permits applications
submitted by Palestinians and is
Jerusalem and the West Bank are rejected
by the Israeli authorities and to make
this even more absurd the guy
the councilman who is responsible
um for rejecting and accepting building
permit applications his name is Jonathan
Youssef and he's a he's a an activist in
the settler movements and he's a
Jerusalem council member
and he last week following the expulsion
of uh
uh a sublaban family and the old city of
Jerusalem he posted to his official
Facebook account nakbanao demanding a
second promising another but he has done
so on many occasions he has chanted with
a megaphone just a few months ago
walking down the street in my
neighborhood so I think we won't knock
by now this is a man who has vandalized
our murals who who has screamed
islamophobic slurs this is literally a
man in the government making these
decisions right uh and this is similar
to you know mercifulyota in the South
Hebron Hills for those who don't know
it's uh it's it's a place in the
occupied West Bank where Bedouin and
cave dweller Palestinians have lived for
Generations they have cultivated the
land
um and recently they were expelled from
their homes over a thousand people were
expelled from their remote small
villages again if you're reading
American Media they would say it would
say Palestinians living in firing zones
were removed because they're living in a
military zone what these media reports
will not tell you that in the 80s the
Israeli government
purposefully classified many lands in
the occupied West Bank
as firing zones as off limit military
zones for the sole purpose of expelling
the residents and this is not some kind
of conspiracy theory this is
Declassified information that was
released from the Israeli State archive
that was later reported on by her audits
also these reports will not tell you
that the judge
who rules on whether these people
continue to live under homes or not is
himself a settler in the West Bank I'm
not even talking about
you know a loose definition of a settler
but according to international law this
is a settler living illegally in an
illegal settlement in the occupied West
Bank this is the Judiciary
um that we deal with which is hilarious
considering how it's being reported on
in American Media recently as some kind
of Beacon of progress and democracy that
the new government is trying to
undermine so there's no representation
in the courts for the Palestinian people
I mean we have lawyers but no there is
no there's no in fact there is for
Palestinians with Israeli citizenships
for example there's over 60 laws that
specifically and explicitly the
scrennines against them
so again it's technically legal the
evictions and the demolitions yeah so
was Jim Crow was legal also you know
when something is legal it can also
still be
wrong absolutely history has shown us
time and time again
um that legality does not necessarily
mean morality and the law you know is uh
the law is a bloodbath in many ways it
has been used
and have used to facilitate the most
horrendous atrocities in in the case of
the Palestinians the law has served to
facilitate and bureaucratize our ethnic
cleansing
do you think there's people
judges and just people in power in the
Judiciary that have hate for the
Palestinian people
I mean I'm not really yeah I need the
the easy simplistic answer is yes but I
don't really care about the contents of
their hearts what I care about the
policy they enact right the laws they
write and enact are hateful demolishing
a person's home
um so you can have somebody from Long
Island New York
who is fleeing you know fraud charges
um this is the case in my house live in
in their in their you know front yard
that's hateful so I don't need you know
confirmation this is something we see a
lot actually you know
um Palestinians and people who are
pro-palestine and just people who want
to make a difference in how this cause
is represented
we often Run for the first
um
opportunity to cite an Israeli being
hateful you know the recent the last uh
Israeli Prime Minister said that he has
killed many Arabs and that he has no
qualms with it
um Netanyahu has said a slew of racist
hateful things
um joachinski the pioneer of Zionism
herzl one of the pioneers of Zionism all
have said horrible hateful
things we also like cannot wait to you
know
site uh uh a confession from a former
Israeli soldier who is guilty
Consciousness is keeping them you know
up at night and we use all of these you
know
confessions or slip UPS as evidence to
prove that this is a racist country that
is an acting race racist acts but we
don't need this because the material
proof is on the ground you see it in the
policies that are enacted you see it
um
in how the country how this regime has
behaved for the past 75 years I don't
need you know
confessions from the likes of Netanyahu
to understand that his heart is full of
hate